Welcome.
We're with the Ismaili dialogue, the master and the disciple.
And the question that follows once the inner has been opened, does the outer still matter?
Only the union of inner and outer is faith.
Inner alone rots like fruit peeled before ripening.
Outer alone is a body without spirit.
Yeah, I mean, imagine you are the seeker here.
You've
You've just been guided through the concealed internal architecture of the cosmos.
The formulas you've recited your entire life suddenly possess these profound structural dimensions.
The heavens have been open for you.
You're seeing the vast, intricate mechanisms behind every ritual you've ever practiced.
The cosmology has been completely laid out.
Yeah, and if you're listening to this, you can probably anticipate the immediate, very human reaction.
Oh, absolutely.
The urgent, immediate question that forms in the mind of the disciple is intensely practical.
You might think, well, if you know the spiritual reality of your physical practices, like fasting and prayer, just an empty motion.
Like, can you simply discard the physical effort now that you have acquired the hidden knowledge?
Precisely.
And the scholar, the master of this chapter, he actually anticipates the question before it's even fully articulated.
He reads the temptation on the seeker's face.
Yeah, he anchors his response in a specific Quranic phrasing, and this phrasing is crucial.
The instruction is not simply about avoiding the physical environment entirely.
The verse states, do not let the life of this physical world deceive you.
Okay, the life of this physical world, not just the physical matter itself.
Exactly.
That distinction is absolutely paramount.
Life, as the scholar explains to the disciple, has four distinct layered meanings.
Okay, lay them out.
So there is physical life in this inferior world, which inevitably passes away.
your biological existence.
Then there is spiritual life in the superior world, which lasts eternally.
And then there's the knowledge of these states.
I mean, you can possess knowledge of the world's outer aspect, which is the lowest form of life, or you can possess knowledge of its inner aspect, which forms the basis for true eternal life.
text is demanding that you recognize which life is actually permanent and which life is simply a temporary vessel.
Because physical knowledge, knowing how to navigate the temporary hierarchies of this world, is forgotten at death.
The soul takes only the spiritual understanding of physical realities into the next realm.
On the day of judgment, the text's promise, an individual will say, I wish I had prepared for my life, meaning the eternal one.
So the question is correctly framed by the disciple then, how do you actually carry the inner into the eternal?
Right, and the scholar answers by outlining the crises that occur when the two dimensions are severed.
He presents the specific cases the seeker needs to hold in mind.
Starting with the inner alone, I assume.
Yes, the first crisis.
The seeker who knows the inner meanings but drops the outer obligations entirely.
They understand the cosmic significance of the cosmos, but they no longer pray.
They no longer fast.
Because they believe the physical action is somehow beneath their new intellectual station.
Exactly.
And the judgment on this state is severe.
The individual becomes one who has rotted from obedience.
Okay, I mean, I don't buy that yet.
Calling the inner only seeker basic is rhetoric, not argument.
You could easily argue that the peel is entirely unnecessary once you know what the fruit tastes like.
The outer layer is just an obstacle to the pure, unmediated experience, you know.
It's not mere rhetoric.
though.
It is a structural argument about severing what Allah commanded to be joined.
The inner meaning simply cannot survive without the protective shell of physical action.
Wait, so the physical practice actually guards the spiritual reality?
Yes, exactly.
It guards it until it is fully formed and secured in the soul.
Without that rigid physical boundary, the spiritual reality spoils.
It is like fruit peeled before riping it rots.
The internal substance dissipates because it is no longer held within the structure of practice.
So without the boundary, the meaning just leaks out and is lost.
Precisely.
The meaning decays.
And this fundamental rotting, well, that's what the tradition refers to as Fisk.
You lose the benefit of both dimensions.
Wow.
I mean, yeah, that makes sense.
Such a person becomes an enemy of the friends of Allah.
and they can never attain their company because they broke the fundamental architecture of the religion.
They assume they were above the structure that was designed to protect their own soul.
Okay, then consider the opposite crisis, which is perhaps even more common.
The person who upholds all the physical rules perfectly but remains entirely ignorant of the inner meaning, the disciple might expect the scholar to call this case acceptable or at least like a safe middle ground since at least the outer is intact.
The community sees them
performing the actions perfectly.
But the scholar declares this the worst station of all.
To uphold the outer while remaining entirely ignorant of the inner makes a person one who buries the seed.
I have to pause you there.
That sounds like wordplay of fear as farmer hiding a seed.
Is etymology dressed as doctrine?
It feels like a linguistic stretch to make a theological point about religious practice.
I get why you'd say that, but it is not a stretch.
It perfectly describes the mechanical reality of the situation.
Think about the physical action.
A farmer hides the seed under the soil, completely blocking it from the light.
The person who knows only the outer hides the inner meaning under the visible action.
The outer action becomes a thick, impenetrable barrier.
Because there is no opening for the light of understanding to enter, the seed of meaning cannot grow.
The individual is a body with no spirit.
They are numbered among the dead.
They perform the physical motions flawlessly, but nothing ever takes root.
So we have two failed states and the mechanics of their failure are clear.
The rotting fruit where the boundary was removed too early and the dead body where the barrier is so thick nothing can penetrate it.
Exactly.
So the pivot for the seeker is the third case, which is the actual doctrine.
Keeping both the inner and outer is the only viable path, a person of faith.
Right, the text recognize this unified individual as the Muman.
This requires the spiritual dimension paired seamlessly with the outer obligations.
Yeah, that framework of daily physical practice.
What we know is Sharia, yes.
Only the union of inner and outer is faith.
Inner alone rots like fruit peel before ripening.
Outer alone is a body without spirit.
That is the core spine of the doctrine.
This pairing of inner and outer as a single living religion is essential.
And here is where it completely transforms the disciples' relationship to daily existence.
Imagine you are in that position.
For the person who achieves this union, this physical world becomes fully licit.
It is repossessed, not refused.
That is a profound shift.
The physical world is not rejected by the believer.
Right, because they see inside the meaning of the world's good things, daily life becomes legible, eating, working, gathering.
None of these are distractions anymore.
The inner of the inner does not subtract from daily existence.
It gives the seeker the absolute right to the world's bounties.
They are the most deserving of the physical world because they actually understand what it is.
But hold on, isn't this just replacing 1 literalism with another?
How is this different from a code?
It sounds like you are simply adding a spiritual checklist to a physical checklist and calling it an enlightened station.
Well, that is exactly what the disciple wonders.
And to answer, we have to turn to the physical toll of this exact attention.
The disciple asks the scholar a very pointed question.
If the true scholars have supposedly repossessed the world, why do they look so pale, so weak, and seemingly reject the physical comforts around them?
Yeah, they aren't physically sick, yet they appear constantly weakened.
And the scholar weeps before answering that question.
He does.
It's A profound emotional moment in the text.
He weeps because the question touches on the immense psychological and physical weight of knowing the truth.
He explains that pale faces record nights in vigil.
The true scholars are absolutely certain of the divine promise and threat, so they hasten to act while they have time.
Their bodies grow weak from fasting.
Their complexions pale.
Yes.
But not because they hate their bodies, it's because their attention is entirely consumed.
They are distracted from luxury by intense reflection.
Right, that deep consuming practice of thinking through what one knows, turning it over until it illuminates everything.
The tradition calls this focused contemplation al-fikr.
And they are simultaneously engrossed in the sweetness of remembrance of Allah.
Yes, the continuous holding of the divine name in the heart, known as dikr Allah.
The pallor of their faces
is not a fast against the world.
It is simply a biological side effect of absolute attention to the next.
Okay, hearing it framed through the biological toll of absolute focus completely changes my perspective.
I concede my earlier point about this being a rigid code.
The physical state isn't a rigid checklist or aesthetic punishment.
It is an honest bodily record of where the heart has spent its hours.
Precisely.
They do not consider the world forbidden.
They are simply occupied elsewhere.
The scholar gives one careful line to explain this.
He says they rejected this physical world only because they were distracted from it by their concern for the next, not because they considered it forbidden.
Yeah, the body grows thin, not as an ascetic feat to win spiritual points, but just as the natural consequence of where the mind resides.
Exactly.
The world was not refused, the mind was occupied elsewhere, and the body recorded where the mind had been.
The father of Imams, peace be upon him, outlined
this generations earlier, actually, in the homily of the God-fearing found in the book The Peak of Eloquence.
Yes, the homily states they pass through the world lightly.
They are lean of body, but their faces carry the light of standing prayer.
Their souls are chased, their needs few.
The vases the scholar describes to the disciple are the very faces the homily already named.
The lean body and the lit face are not asceticism for its own sake.
The body just reflects the mind's location.
But you know, that realization creates a massive problem for the disciple.
This brings us to the deepest issue, the origin of creatures.
How so?
Well, if bodies just reflect minds and if we are all created by the same God, why do people differ so drastically in their opinions and their paths?
It is the ultimate question of divine justice.
If God is just,
Why is one person a true scholar and another completely ignorant?
Exactly.
And the scholar explains that external physical instruments are perfectly equal.
Bodies vary in language and color as a sign of power, so people may recognize one another, but the underlying equipment is standard.
Right, no scholar has three eyes.
No ignorant person has only one.
Because the external design is identical, the inner instruments of will, intellect, and reasoning are also identical in every chest, governed by the pattern of divine justice.
The Creator would not treat his creatures justly in their outer aspect and unjustly in their inner aspect.
Exactly.
He has not placed two hearts in the scholar's chest, nor forbidden any means of understanding for the ignorant.
The instrument of knowledge is the exact same.
So the judgment falls entirely on the use of the equipment, not the equipment itself.
We turn to the chapter on the heights, verse 179.
which reads, they have hearts but do not understand with them.
It establishes the ultimate argument against those who fail to employ what they were given.
The argument is not that the ignorant lack the instrument and so are somehow not at fault.
No, it is that they possess the perfect instrument and simply refuse to use it.
The difference between the scholar and the masses is not the equipment, it is the use.
Differential response, not differential equipment, is the entire basis on which divine judgment can be considered just.
So how does the divergence actually happen then?
If everyone has the same tools, how do we end up so far apart?
Well, the scholar says it comes from the root being corrupted.
All came from Adam and Adam from dust.
But generations left behind the inherited divine way.
The foundational inherited pattern.
Yes, what the texts refer to as a sinna.
The scholar explains this divergence using a brilliant image.
He says people are like archers at one target, identical bows, unequal hits.
The bows being the identical inner instruments, the intellect, the will, the capacity to reason.
Yes.
Think about the mechanics of archery.
You can have a perfectly crafted bow, but if you abandon the proper stance, if you leave behind the inherited way, your footing slips.
The root corrupts.
Exactly.
People seek fleeting, immediate pleasures over eternal recompense.
They shoot with the identical bow, but their corrupted intention and poor stance cause them to miss the target entirely.
And the prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family, delivered the clear message, but the factions splintered because they abandoned that stance.
They did.
And this leads directly to the practical, everyday application of obedience.
The foundation of action requires carrying out all obligations and abstaining from all that is prohibited.
This material purification, the zakat of the body.
Yes, with the tradition term zakat al-Aptan.
It requires staying in gratitude and treating people as you would want them to treat you.
But the scholar addresses the ultimate test of this system.
What happens when pure necessity breaks the outer rule?
He tells this devastating story of the thirsting woman.
Imagine the desperation of this scene.
She was wandering, terribly thirsty for three days.
She feared her children were going to die of dehydration.
She finally found a man with water, but he demanded a condition from her in exchange for it.
Facing the death of her children and herself, she complied with the man's condition solely to secure the water.
And the second caliph heard of this event.
Acting purely on the outer rule, he looked at the broken prohibition and ordered her to be stoned.
He acted exactly like the farmer hiding the seed.
He saw the outer structure of the law and applied it with rigid, unyielding literalism.
completely blocking out the inner light of the situation.
But the father of imams intervened and freed her.
He completely reversed the judgment.
He did this by citing the verse of necessity.
Whoever is forced by necessity, neither desiring the forbidden nor willingly disobeying,
There is no sin upon him.
It completely synthesizes the stakes of everything we have discussed.
The literalist sees only the broken rule and arrives at punishment.
But the one who has united the inner and the outer looks at the exact same physical reality, sees the undeniable necessity of preserving life, and applies the divine mercy.
The same instrument of moral reasoning, exercised by one who has seen the inner of the verse, arrives at mercy.
Mercy under necessity is not a loophole or a violation of the law.
It is the realization of the verse itself.
Three movements, one unified doctrine.
The disciple learns that discovering the inner meaning does not cancel out daily life.
It makes daily life finally legible as a doctrine.
Only the union of inner and outer is faith.
Inner alone rots like fruit peeled before ripening.
Outer alone is a body without spirit.
Which obligation have you kept without its inner, or which inner without its obligation, and what would the Union ask of you this week?